-You have a new album out
right now,
"Great Songs From Stage
And Screen."
I love that you did this.
You know I'm a fan
of your singing, as well.
Does this come from
your parents?
How did you get into
the crooning and the singing?
-It does, yeah.
It was something that my parents
always felt was a very important
part of childhood,
allowing the brain to develop
properly
required the inclusion of music.
-Would they have parties, or
would they just have records?
-Yeah, there were parties.
My dad played the guitar.
A friend of my parents started
a church choir when I was a kid,
and believe it or not,
I was in it.
-Wow.
-If you can picture me
in a church choir.
-I can't, I really can't.
-But nonetheless. Yes.
-Wow.
And are these songs inspired by
them, or just songs you like?
-These are all just --
it's just a hodgepodge of songs
all from films or shows
that I just felt like,
you know, had never really had
a proper arrangement
written for them
in a pop format.
So it's a very light,
bubbly album.
-It must be fun to do this
with the orchestra.
I mean, it's a big production.
It sounds amazing.
-Yeah, I love it.
I mean, it's my favorite part
of the film process
is the score,
but, yeah, we recorded this
at Abbey Road.
-No!
-Yeah, yeah.
-You had to cross the street,
I'm assuming.
-Cross the street?
Oh, yes, yes.
From the other side
of the street.
Oh, yeah. Oh, The Beatles,
-The Beatles. Yeah. Yeah.
You got to do that.
-I think it's the fourth
or fifth album
that we've done there.
-Oh, really?
So you're used to this.
What is it like inside?
I've never gone inside.
-It's a cool place.
And what's interesting about it
is there's carpeting,
there's wood paneling,
at least when I was there.
Structural elements that look
like, you know,
if you were in someone's house,
you'd go,
"It might be time to replace
this floor or this carpet.
Looks like it's been there
forever, and it's just filthy."
-Yeah.
-But there's sort of a feeling
that, look, we don't know
what makes these acoustics
so magical, so we're not going
to mess with anything.
I think part of it is
superstition,
and part of it is just
you really never know
what that X factor is, and so
best not to mess with it.
-Did you get to the roof at all,
or no?
-No, I didn't go to the roof.
-Oh, yeah.
-Is there something on the roof?
-That's the Beatles. Right?
Didn't they do it on the roof
of Abbey Road.
-Oh, is that where they...
-Recorded "Let It Be."
-Yeah.
And that's where they got
stopped by the police,
and it was -- Yeah.
Well, if you make another album,
I'll meet you out there.
-Was it "Sgt. Pepper's" that
they just put a speaker
in a window and blasted it out
into the street,
and that was how they
introduced it to the world?
-I mean, it's just --
-It may be apocryphal.
I remember reading that story is
that they just opened a window,
here's the new record,
and people just stopped
and listened.
-That must feel so cool
to record in Abbey Road.
-It was fun. It was fun.
-I love the cover,
by the way, as well.
With this type of music, I feel
like it is a solo mission.
It's almost, you want it to look
lonely or something.
But was it done pre-COVID
or pre-quarantine?
-Yeah, there's some stuff
that we had to do back here
because obviously we couldn't
get back there,
but most of it was done there
prior to all this mess.
-Well, congrats on the album.
As if you're not busy enough,
executive produced
"Cosmos: Possible Worlds."
Tell everyone about this season.
-This season,
"Cosmos: Possible Worlds,"
Ann Druyan once again is back
as showrunner,
along with Brannon Braga.
Neil deGrasse Tyson
obviously is back.
And this is great. You know,
it's taken us a long while
to get this thing
back on the air.
It's been a long wait for
audiences, and yet here it is.
And, you know, we sort of feel
like at this point in time
There's nothing that feels more
necessary or relevant than --
than something that elevates
the enterprise of science,
I think. I think we can take
all we can get right now.
So it's -- much like the
original, it's fun,
it's colorful, it's lively,
it's surprising.
I think people
are going to dig it.
-I want to show a clip.
Here's a look at
"Cosmos: Possible Worlds."
Check it out.
-The DNA double helix.
Star stuff.
Oxygen, carbon, nitrogen --
elements cooked in the hearts
of distant scars
combined with hydrogen
from the big bang
to become alive
on this little world.
Through random changes,
mutations in the genes,
some of which led to more
successful life forms,
what we call evolution
by natural selection,
the ladder grew,
adding more and more rungs.
It took another three billion
years for life to evolve
the complexity of the plants
and animals that you could see
with the naked eye.
♪♪
-My thanks to Seth MacFarlane.
"Cosmos:Possible Worlds"
premiers September 22nd
at 8:00 p.m. on Fox,
and check out "Great Songs From
Stage And Screen," out now.